and as we zoom out across space and time
and look at earth
why do you think
we're here
on this earth
what's
the meaning of human civilization what's
the meaning of your life
of individual
human life
and
broadly speaking what is the meaning of
life
skye fitzgerald no boy
yeah
uh
for me per i can speak personally on
that only and that's that i i believe
that the meaning of my life
is to try to make the world a little bit
better before i go
um you know i
when i was in theater and grad school
i directed a play called shadowlands by
c.s lewis
and there's a quote from that it goes
like this
we are like blocks of stone out of which
the sculptor carves the forms of men
the blows of his chisel
which hurt us so much
are what make us perfect
now i would take away the perfect part
right
but i think i've remembered that quote
for so many years
because i believe in the underlying
notion
that
the blows of the chisel which are the
experiences that we go through shape us
right necessarily so and hopefully shape
us into a better human being and in my
case
a human being that i hope can make the
world a little better
you know through those blows
before it's over yeah before it's over
before you go as you said you think
about that
you think about the the going part
your mortality you ever think about that
you said you don't have a death wish you
tried to minimize risk but eventually
it's going to be over yeah for all of us
absolutely i'll speak for yourself
well you've got other plans for
something tend to merge
i'm going to merge with robots
embody nothing
not not at all yes for all of us
unfortunately or fortunately or who who
the heck knows
um but do you
um ponder your mortality
are you afraid of it
i live with my my mortality knowing that
that it's fleeting now that my life is
fleeting and that that
i'm gonna go into the ground just like
everyone else or maybe as ashes you know
um
so i live with that knowledge every day
but i don't allow it
to stop me or hold me up rather i really
it drives me
and it drives me to try to get as much
done as i can before i go
right
yeah so the knowledge of your death
uh is a kind of dance partner
and you try to dance beautifully
this guy you're an incredible human um
incredible artist and filmmaker
and it's a huge honor that you would sit
and
spend your really valuable time with me
today i really really enjoyed this
conversation
thanks for having me lex and thanks for
doing what you do
you